what was that
honda yes dear are you using your powers
to turn on the light
yes dude allow me sweetheart
what do you see only your lovely rose
bushes
that's all are you using your night
vision vision
i assure you my love i see nothing of
this you have absolutely no reason to
were saying how's it going everybody
it's warren welcome back to the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things mcu and
last night we got
this official clip of the wanda vision
series that aired on jimmy kimmel
giving us a tiny little glimpse of what
to expect at least from
one episode of the one division series
now in this particular clip we don't
really learn much about what the show is
about
marvel studios has actually done a very
good job at keeping the main plot of the
show
pretty much a mystery we know that it's
going to slightly cover the house of
m storyline which i'll get to in this
video and we also know it involves
fake or alternate realities but besides
that things are still pretty much a
mystery
now we do know that it's going to go
through different sitcoms and in this
clip right here it's taken straight from
bewitched
wanda hears something outside and she
uses her powers to turn it off and on
we get a little bit of the old slapstick
humor here we also see that the beds are
separated because fun fact back then
during that
sitcom era it was illegal to put the
beds together and show them on tv
now we've already seen that as they move
through the air as they're going to move
those beds together but until they do
that something really interesting in
this scene that i've kind of pointed out
before
is what's in between their beds the
shadow now this is a shadow of one of
the bed posts but it's very curious how
it looks like a witch's hat
and as many of you know we're going to
see the true scarlet witch
in this series they're finally going to
address her as her comic book name
the scarlet witch now due to so many
sitcom
type clips coming out for the one
division series some people have been
asking are they actually going to adapt
the house of them storyline in this
series
and yes they are this has already
actually been confirmed by kevin feige
and by elizabeth olsen herself
but the one division series isn't just
going to be an adaptation of the house
of m series there will be many different
ones especially when it comes to the
earlier episodes of all of these sitcoms
but eventually the reality will break
and then the series will start to dive
into more of the whole
multiverse of madness concept the house
of m storyline and what leads up to it
wanda kind of losing control on reality
and then creating her
own reality where mutants rule the world
and then we'll go
right into doctor strange too and
speaking of doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness unfortunately
elizabeth olsen had a little bit of an
update for us that wasn't exactly good
news
elizabeth olsen said that unfortunately
due to london
being on lockdown doctor strange 2
filming is on pause
due to england's new lockdown so the
shooting for doctor strange 2 is on hold
right now but let's hope that this
doesn't last for much longer but no need
to fear we still have over a year until
we get doctor strange in the multiverse
of madness plenty of time to film and
get everything ready
but be sure to subscribe so you stay up
to date on all of the latest mcu news
for one division doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness and the rest of
the mcu
don't forget to like this video and let
me know your thoughts on this clip in
the comments down below and how excited
you are to finally see the wanda vision
series
in just nine days for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof